For all the first-time flyers, I'll explain turning flight to you for the very beginning.
Once we're off the ground, the important thing is that right after launch we hold the direction and come out straight.
Just flying straight away from the slope is the first priority for us.
And as soon as we're clear of the hill, we can try going for short turns,
we can pull in, wiggle the brake a little, and if that's not enough,
then we have to reach back here into the riser as much as possible,
as much as we can get our weight into it in every case.
Then with every turn, always first look in the direction of the airspace where I want to turn.
Is it clear? I don't want to initiate a turn and fly straight into another pilot's canopy.
So I look, airspace clear, and before we then work with the brakes,
always
first put the weight onto that side.
And as you can see, with a seat board it works very well, and if you have your legs free, you can lay the left leg
over the right one and get even more body shift that way.
And only then do we add the brake to support it.
Work the brake slowly, and once you feel, okay, it could use a bit more,
or I'll tell you, here, another 3 cm, you could pull another 3 cm.
Coming out of the turn is always led by sitting back into the riser.
And I call out pretty much everything to you, so normally you'll start out
with the brakes applied.
Look to the turn side, weight, and then a bit more inside brake.
The other brake may even come up a touch, and I'll call all of that out for you.
And coming out, you always shift your weight back to neutral first and then
apply the outside brake, so we always come out braked, out of any turn or any dynamic
build-up.